bon confirmé le château fermé confiné
mais on continue à travailler d'ailleurs
on en train de planter un berger depuis
le confinement les jardiniers de
cheverny plante des arbres fruitiers
plusieurs centaines c'est la saison au
rayon cerisier sami s'occupe d'un
morency là plusieurs variétés
oui il ya du bigarreau il ya pas mal il
ya du coeur des pigeons il ya là pas mal
de variétés on va planter dans de la
bonne terre dans un terreau est un
mélange de terreau et terre végétale et
on va arroser abondamment derrière on on
va arroser
on va remplir la cuve est tournoi trois
ou quatre fois et aura un engrais à
mettre aussi derrière le projet un
jardin sucré pour le printemps un verger
à la française sur un hectare tout en
rondeur un labyrinthe gourmand de 360
grand fruitiers rangés par espèce ici on
a des cas on a des ça doit être des
mirabelles avec plusieurs donc du coup
bonus à plusieurs variétés de en avoir
cinq qui verdure l'aller donc on a des
poiriers encore dans et sur la droite on
a des filles et quand on plante un
verger on sait qu'on peut avoir une
première récolte de fruits qui ressemble
un petit peu quelque chose pas avant
deux trois ans on se prenait toujours
dans un très très long terme
penser à demain aux fleurs aux fruits
oubliés le présent ou l'occupé pour
garder l'espoir
tous les jours on se dit peut-être que
demain
on pourra ouvrir alors au lieu de rester
enfermé avec aucun projet on se dit de
toutes les façons il faut faire en sorte
d'envisager que au moins puisse ouvrir
pendant les vacances de noël installé
les décors de noël la féerie donne déjà
de morale l'idée c'est que c'est que les
visiteurs en ai plein les yeux qu'on ait
ce roi ou en rentrant et tout au long de
la visite extérieure ou intérieure et ça
fait beaucoup de bien celui qu'il fait
aussi ce vernis se tient prêt pour
l'avenir pour demain au cas où